He was beloved by many as Theo Sipowicz on
NYPD Blue, but Austin Majors' tragic death
at age 27 devastated his friends, family, and
the millions who grew up watching him on TV.
On February 13, 2023, TMZ reported that
actor Austin Majors died at the age of
27. According to the publication, he
passed away on Sunday, February 12,
while staying at a homeless living facility
located in Los Angeles, California.
An unspecified source told TMZ that Majors' death
may have come as a result of him ingesting a fatal
amount of fentanyl, but this is unconfirmed as
of February 14, 2023. The autopsy is set to be
completed soon, with the results said
to arrive sometime within the next few
months. Coinciding with the news of his death,
Majors' family released a statement that read,
"[He] was a loving, artistic, brilliant, and kind
human being. Austin took great joy and pride in
his acting career. He was an active Eagle Scout
and graduated Salutatorian in High School. He went
on to graduate from USC's School of Cinematic Arts
with a passion of directing and music producing."
They also added that the entire family will carry
fond memories of their time with him, and that
they will miss him forever. Though his acting
career wasn't long, Austin Majors racked up some
high-profile credits and entertained audiences
the world over before his untimely passing.
He got his start in the entertainment world as
a child actor, starting out strong with a few
feature-length credits. Among his earliest film
appearances were Nevada and The Prince of Air from
1997 and 2000, respectively. In 2002, he even got
the chance to try out voice acting in the Disney
flop, Treasure Planet, where he took on the role
of a young Jim Hawkins. While he'd continue to
appear at the movies intermittently throughout
the remainder of his career, there's no denying
that Majors' television work is what put him on
the map. Most famously, Majors appeared quite
frequently on the police procedural NYPD Blue,
popping up in 48 episodes between 1999 and 2004.
"Theo, Theo, don't, don't plop your mashed
potatoes all over the table. C'mon. Just eat up."
His work in the role of Theo Sipowicz,
the son of Detective Andy Sipowicz,
paved the way for him to try out
other TV ventures, including ER,
NCIS, and Desperate Housewives. However, none
of these programs kept Majors around nearly as
long as NYPD Blue ultimately did. His final
acting credit is a Season 4 episode of How I
Met Your Mother titled "Right Place Right Time,"
rounding out a pretty solid yet brief filmography.
Following his time as an actor, Austin
Majors decided to chart a new course
in life. As mentioned previously, he made his
way to the University of Southern California,
where he took up a major in film and television
production with a minor in music on the side.
Instead of using his education to become a movie
star or return to being a frequent face on TV,
Majors chose to continue pursuing different
passions in the field of entertainment.
Majors maintained a clear interest in working
in film and television — as evidenced by his
LinkedIn page, where he expressed his desire
to do everything from directing to editing
in various kinds of visual media. Furthermore,
Majors would also embrace his musical side. He
began producing music under the name "Pope !",
and even had some songs available on Spotify.
It was clear that no matter the avenue, Austin
Majors had an insatiable desire to follow and
succeed at his creative passions. By family,
friends, and fans alike, he will be sorely missed.